[Applaus]
[Musik]
oktober 2001 begann die usa unter der
führung des damaligen präsidenten george
hw bush und mit unterstützung britischer
truppen die operation enduring freedom
zu deutsch operation andauerndes
freiheit die invasion afghanistans war
eine direkte reaktion auf die
terroranschläge vom 11 september
desselben jahres in
nur wenigen wochen wurden die taliban
von der macht verdrängt ihr anführer
mullah omar musste in die berge flüchten
und die von bin laden geführte
organisation al qaida erlitt einen
schweren schlag
[Musik]
und trotzdem zog sich der krieg noch
weitere 20 jahre hin 20 quälend lange
jahre in denen mehr als 7000 soldaten
und söldner der usa und anderer nato
staaten halten sollten und natürlich
mehr als 70.000 angehörige der
afghanischen armee und polizei darüber
hinaus sollte dieser krieg auch über
zwei billionen dollar kosten natürlich
konnte sich damals kaum jemand
vorstellen welchen ausgang der längste
krieg der geschichte der usa nehmen
sollte und denjenigen die sich das
damals vorstellen konnten war ein
schnelles ende ihrer politischen oder
militärischen karriere sicher aber nun
ist ist genauso gekommen wie es die
damals als querulanten und verräter
verschwinden kritiker vorhergesagt
hatten nach vielen jahren zähen kampfs
erlangten die taliban wieder die macht
und die amerikaner sagen sich mit einem
schmerzhaften rückzug konfrontiert der
vom chaos eile und sogar
dschihadistischen angriffen der dash
geprägt war 20 jahre der hoffnung aber
auch der illusion gehen jetzt den bach
runter in unserem letzten video über
afghanistan haben wir uns mit den
schlüsselfaktoren beschäftigt die den
schnellen fall der republik afghanistan
an die taliban erklären allerdings haben
wir noch viele fragen offen gelassen zum
beispiel wie genau ist die taliban
geschafft haben die ganzen jahre über
der amerikanischen großmacht zu trotzen
welche verbindungen zum internationalen
terrorismus unterhalten und vielleicht
die wichtigste frage von allen welche
zukunft steht afghanistan nun bevor wie
werden die bahn in ihrem neuen
gottesstaaten regieren in diesen zweiten
video unserer afghanistan trilogie
werden wer all diese fragen beantworten
und das erste grundlegendste was wir
hier zuerst mal verstehen müssen ist wer
genau die taliban eigentlich sind also
aufgepasst politik im religiösen
fundamentalismus
wenn wir die entstehungsgeschichte der
taliban ergründen wollen müssen wir uns
auf eine zeitreise in die frühen 1990 er
jahre begeben 1989 zogen die letzten
sowjetischen truppen nach zehn jahren
krieg in dem das land gründlich
verwüstet worden war aus afghanistan
das von ihnen installierte
kommunistische regime sollte sich zwar
noch bis 1992 halten der faktor
übernahmen jedoch die mudschaheddin
gemacht jene islamischen wohl aus weil
sie die ganze zeit über von den usa
unterstützt ausgerüstet und ausgebildet
worden waren um dies auch jetzt zu
bekämpfen das ergebnis waren erbitterte
machtkämpfe und massive korruption
das land versank erneuten krieg diesmal
in einem bürgerkrieg
dies war die gemengelage in welcher eine
gruppe religiöser fanatiker namens
taliban angeführt von mullah omar sprach
die anarchie zu beenden und islamische
werte durchzusetzen im jahr 1996
erreichten sie ihr ziel sie zogen in
kabul ein und übernahmen die kontrolle
über das land nach ihrem sieg riefen sie
ein islamisches emirat aus uns da hinten
über afghanistan eine der strecken und
ja wahnsinnigsten religiösen diktaturen
seiner geschichte unmenschliche strafe
massaker an minderheiten und die brutale
unterdrückung aller frauen die
eigentlich nicht mehr als menschliche
wesen angesehen wurden bestimmten von
nun an das leben der afghanen im grunde
die hölle auf erden darüber hinaus boten
sie auch terroristischen gruppen wie al
qaida unterschlupf eine sichere
operationsbasis weshalb die usa 2001 als
antwort auf den angriff auf die twin
towers in das land einmarschierten
[Applaus]
die taliban sind eine radikale militant
religiöse gruppe eine organisation die
von fanatikern angeführt wird die nicht
sogar jedes mittel einzusetzen dass
ihnen zur verfügung steht um ihre macht
zu sichern und ihr weltbild
durchzusetzen einschließlich grausamer
anschläge im jahr 2014 kann ist jedoch
zu einer gewissen verschiebung der
damalige taliban führer mullah mansur
argumentierte dass die gruppe auch eine
politische strategie entwickeln und die
bevölkerung nicht durch pure angst
sondern durch die lenkung und kontrolle
der korruption für sich gewinnen müsse
von diesem moment an eröffneten die
taliban ein büro in doha um
internationale verhandlungen zu
erleichtern sie begannen auch sich um
die verwaltung des öffentlichen dienstes
zu kümmern und korrupte beamte zu
verfolgen
sie sollten zum beispiel dafür dass
erste die von der afghanischen regierung
bezahlt wurden einen anreiz hatten in
öffentlichen krankenhäusern zu arbeiten
anstatt ausschließlich in privatkliniken
sie nahmen auch tadschiken und usbeken
in den führungsrat der taliban auf um
ihren einfluss über die paschtunischen
gebiete hinaus auszuweiten im grunde
adaptierten die taliban eine klassische
zuckerbrot und peitsche strategie indem
sie zur peitsche die sie schon die ganze
zeit zu schwingen wussten noch etwas
zucker brot hinzufügten mit dieser
strategie schafften sie es eine menge
unterstützer in der bevölkerung zu
gewinnen und wir jetzt gesehen haben hat
sich diese strategie ihre wirkung bis
heute bewahrt trotzdem dürfen wir uns
nichts vormachen eine zuckerbrot und
peitsche strategie ist eine sache ihr
ziel jedoch eine ganz andere
alles nur 2016 nach einem
us-drohnenangriff viele nannten die
taliban diesen kerl zum obersten führer
mullah
baradar ein typ der es so radikal ist
dass er nicht nur die selbstaufopferung
erwartet sondern sogar seinen eigenen
suchen dazu ermutigte ein märtyrer zu
werden diese opferte sich dann auch im
alter von 23 jahren bei einem
selbstmordanschlag gestern mit die
taliban ischen etwas besser kennen gibt
es fragen die wir beantworten müssen
nicht zum beispiel wie haben sie die 20
jahre krieg überlebt der alles leute im
grunde auf die frage hinaus wie die
taliban die ganze zeit über all ihre
aktivitäten finanziert haben krieg
kosten schließlich geld eine menge geld
also schwitzt eure ohren denn die
antwort auf diese frage wird euch nicht
gleichgültig lassen
[Musik]
das kolumbien des opiums
auf den ersten blick mag man diesen
eindruck nicht haben aber die wahrheit
ist dass die taliban in den letzten
jahren wie vielleicht best finanzierte
auf dänische gruppe der welt geworden
sind um die eine vorstellung zu geben
nach schätzungen der vereinten nationen
verfügten die taliban noch vor ihrer
machtübernahme in carbon über jährliche
einnahmen zwischen 300 millionen und 1,6
milliarden dollar und dies behaupten
nicht nur die vereinten nationen die
meisten quellen weisen auf einnahmen
hinter jedes jahr die schwelle von einer
milliarde dollar überschreiten du siehst
also die taliban sind beileibe keine
amateure wir reden hier von einer echten
professionellen kampftruppe eine gut
finanzierte gut ausgebildete und gut
strukturierte organisation und die große
frage die preisfrage die wir uns alle
stellen müssen lautet woher in aller
welt bekommen die taliban das ganze geld
nun im wesentlichen aus einem riesigen
katalog krimineller aktivitäten wie
drogenerfahrungen und illegalen bergbau
hinzu kommen noch spenden aus ländern
wie pakistan saudi arabien und katar an
allererster stelle jedoch steht der
rauschgifthandel und tatsache ist dass
afghanistan für opium das ist was
kolumbien für das weiße pulver darstellt
[Musik]
laut dem büro der vereinten nationen für
drogen- und verbrechensbekämpfung
produziert afghanistan fast 90 des
weltweiten für uns der schlüssel
substanz für die herstellung von harry
afghanistan ist damit zu einem der
bedeutendsten drogen staaten auf dem
planeten worden ein globaler knotenpunkt
der eine große zahl der weltweiten
drogen märkte versorgt und nicht nur das
in den letzten jahren hat die
afghanischen drogen industrie damit
begonnen sich zu diversifizieren
zusätzlich zum opium haben sie begonnen
gera zu verwerten eine pflanze liegt
überall im land wächst um ephedrin und
amphetamin herzustellen zwei
verbindungen die weitaus lukrativer sind
als opium und die vor den
drogenbekämpfung banken der inzwischen
aufgelösten afghanischen regierung als
auf die ganze welt zu rollende
katastrophe bezeichnet werden
[Musik]
tatsache ist dass die nach außen
strenggläubigen taliban überhaupt kein
problem damit haben sich an dieser
lukrativen aber illegal und gänzlich und
islamischen industrie worden gleich zu
beteiligen es wird geschätzt dass ihr
schnitt mindestens zehn prozent beträgt
und das sind die konservativen
schätzungen genau aus diesem grund ist
es keine überraschung dass die drei
wichtigsten opium produzieren provinzen
helmand und kandahar und urusgan
gleichzeitig hochburgen der taliban sind
und aufgepasst denn wir reden hier nicht
über kindergeld
[Musik]
der export von opium seinen derivaten
und von methamphetaminen ist der größte
außenhandels posten des ganzen landes
mehr noch tatsächlich übersteigen
afghanistans drogen exporte bei weitem
alle anderen exportgüter
zusammengenommen schätzungen zufolge
geht es um umsätze von weit über 3
milliarden dollar pro jahr somit hätte
das taliban imperium jedes jahr zwischen
300 und 500 mio dollar des schmutzigen
drogen geldes erhalten ganz schön
heuchlerisch nicht wahr oder in der
sprache der formen gotteskrieger durch
und durch vom opiumanbau und heroin
produktion sind gefährlicher als die
sowjetische invasion unter angriff auf
unser land es ist gefährlicher als die
fraktionsgrenzen afghanistan fest ist
gefährlicher als der terrorismus hamid
karzai ehemaliger präsident afghanistans
was jedoch noch paradoxer ist obwohl wir
es hier mit haupt einnahmequelle der
taliban zu tun haben ist die fläche für
den mohnanbau aus dem das rohopium
gewonnen wird in den letzten jahren
stetig gewachsen und das obwohl die amis
mehr als neun milliarden dollar
ausgegeben haben um das problem zu
bekämpfen 9 milliarden dollar total für
die kasse denn seit dem einmarsch der
usa zu einer zeit als die taliban
übrigens selbst den mohnanbau verboten
hatten hat sich die größe der plantagen
um nicht weniger als 40 vervielfacht
aber rauschgift ist bei weitem nicht die
einzige einnahmequelle der taliban
der bergbau stellt ein weiteres
wichtiges business dar nach
informationen der uno konnten die
taliban im jahr 2020 etwa 400 millionen
dollar aus der besteuerung illegale
minen einnehmen ein betrag der sich mit
vielen unabhängigen schätzungen deckt
und weit über dem liegt was die
afghanische regierung selbst aus diesem
sektor einnahmen tatsächlich macht und
es die taliban zur priorität so schnell
wie möglich die kontrolle über die
rohstoffreichsten regionen des landes zu
erlangen um sich diese wichtige
finanzierungsquelle zu sichern vorne
lapis lazuli minen im nördlichen in
badakhshan bis zu gold blei und zink
ihnen in helmond oder talg und nahm
ihnen im südlichen kandahar
[Musik]
die taliban vergaben eigenmächtig
bergbaulizenzen um die vorkommen maximal
auszubeuten kontrollierten der transport
und organisierten sogar die
arbeitskräfte einen weiteren wichtigen
einnahmeposten stellen neben aus stücken
bergbau mautgebühren auf landstraßen und
grenzübergängen da und so bauten die
taliban sozusagen einen mafia imperium
auf das ihnen genug ressourcen
verschaffte und ihre 70 bis 100.000 mann
starke armee zu finanzieren nachschub
und wasser zu kaufen und natürlich
afghanischer beamter zu bestechen dies
war einer der schlüssel um den krieg zu
gewinnen so jetzt wo wir also wissen wo
das geld der taliban her kommt dass sie
dazu bewegt hat wieder die macht zu
kommen stellt sich die nächste
schlüsselfrage eine frage welche nicht
nur die zukunft afghanistans sondern die
der ganzen welt bestimmen wird welche
verbindungen genau unterhalten sie zum
internationalen terrorismus also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
funktionsschuhe fraktionen
die usa die nato sind vor fast 20 jahren
in afghanistan einmarschiert weil die
taliban der terrororganisation al qaida
unterschlupf geboten und da die taliban
wieder an der macht sind könnte man
meinen dass nun wieder alles von vorne
losgeht alle al kaida anhänger feiern
die entwicklungen es ist ein sieg über
die vereinigten staaten was sie zu
erreichen hoffen viele gruppen werden
diesen sieg propagandistisch
ausschlachten wenn die taliban es können
könnt ihr es auch peter neumann
professor für sicherheitsstudien am
king's college london wenn das abkommen
mit den taliban das von der tramp
regierung ausgehandelt und dann von
beiden umgesetzt wurde jedoch etwas
deutlich gemacht hat dann dass sich die
taliban im gegenzug für die übergabe
afghanistans in ihre hände lasst uns
verpflichtet haben zu verhindern dass
terroristische gruppen das land als
operationszentrum und sicheren hafen
nutzen die frage ist aber ob man taliban
überhaupt trauen kann nun hierzu gibt es
meinungen für jeden geschmack es gibt
analysten die meinen dass die taliban
ihre lektion gelernt haben und nicht
bereit sein werden ihre macht zu
organisationen wie al qaida zu riskieren
andere gehen jedoch davon aus dass diese
gruppe und auch andere wieder
reaktiviert werden weil sie durch die
taliban einfach nicht aktiv bekämpft
werden und pass auf wenn es war der
us-verteidigungsminister leute aus zu
höchstpersönlich der vor dem senat aus
sagte dass das risiko dass genau dieses
szenario eintritt signifikant ist
in einem bericht an den un
sicherheitsrat aus dem mai 2021 heißt es
dass al kaida in mindestens 15
afghanischen provinzen präsent ist und
weiterhin engen kontakt zu den taliban
schlägt auch wenn diese sich darüber
strengstens bedeckt halten und das
abkommen doha nicht so gefährden laut
denselben berichte deuten religiöse
verwandtschaft familiäre beziehungen
durch ehen zwischen den beiden gruppen
und jahrelange gemeinsame kämpfte dass
die verbindungen zwischen taliban und al
qaida immer noch sehr stark sind doch al
qaida dürfte die kleinste unserer sorgen
darstellen die organisation ist
mittlerweile geschwächt laut einem
bericht des us verteidigungsministeriums
geht es ihr im grunde ums überleben und
außerdem scheint die anführer also war
ich krank zu sein heute erscheint die
größte bedrohung für die internationale
gemeinschaft von dem zu kommen was als
sk bekannt ist der sogenannte islam
start in der curasan provinz eine
fraktion der dash die für den
schrecklichen terroranschlag am kabuler
flughafen verantwortlich war massaker am
kabuler flughafen 13 amerikanische
soldaten und mehr als 100 weitere
menschen sterben der punkt ist dass es
im prinzip eine rivalisierende gruppe zu
den taliban darstellt und in der tat was
meinst du was die taliban als erstes
taten nachdem sie kabul eingenommen und
die kontrolle über das dortige gefängnis
erlangt hatten nun schauen sie mal an
taliban exekutieren ehemaligen esk chef
ein jahr nachdem die afghanische
regierung ihn verhaftete gsk kam 2014
ins land und gewann anhänger vor allem
unter unzufriedenen taliban sie
präsentiert sich als eine radikalere
alternative zu den taliban und das will
schon was heißen und natürlich versuchen
sie dies durch das höchstmögliche maß an
exzessiver gewalt unter beweis zu
stellen terroranschläge auf schulen und
krankenhäuser bei denen kinder und
schwangere abgemessen werden und alle
arten extremer barbarei es für diese
gruppe kein tabu in der tat sehen sowohl
die usa als auch der rest der
internationalen gemeinschaft
einschließlich russlands und chinas sie
als wahre gefahr in afghanistan
tatsache ist eben auch dass sie offen
mit den taliban realisieren und sich mit
diesen praktisch im krieg befinden aber
liegen die ziele dieser beiden
radikalislamischen gruppen wirklich so
weit auseinander die taliban sind dem
islamischen staat viel näher als die
behaupten jana ingo hell direktor für
internationale sicherheit bei der asia
pacific foundation and foreign policy
und dies ist beileibe keine
einzelmeinung denn an dieser stelle
müssen wir uns über das hakkani netzwerk
unterhalten
das hakkani netzwerk ist der radikalste
gewalttätigste und militärisch fitteste
zweiter der taliban so etwas die
prätorianergarde des neuen islamischen
emirat ich glaube nicht dass
irgendjemand im westen die reichweite
des hakkani-netzwerks vollständig
versteht es ist die beeindruckendste
nichtstaatliche terrorgruppe die ich je
gesehen habe mit ausnahme von eises in
den letzten zwei jahren des kalifats
michael caine pensionierte
generalleutnant der us-armee und
ehemaliger direktor für strategie am
national counterterrorism center
deswegen war das hakkani netzwerk an
dass die taliban als ganzes von den usa
als terroristische gruppe betrachtet und
kein wunder diese organisation war neben
vielen anderen aktionen für schreckliche
anschläge verantwortlich die hunderte
und aberhunderte von us-soldaten bürger
verbündeter länder und angehörige der
afghanischen armee das leben gekostet
haben es gibt außerdem hinweise darauf
dass das hakkani netzwerk tatsächlich
mit gsk kollaboriert hat und dies auch
weiterhin gut im austausch für die
verfolgung gemeinsamer ziele leistet es
ihn zum beispiel technische hilfe ebenso
sind viele ansicht vom bombenanschlag
auf den tabula flughafen hätten indirekt
auch die taliban und vor allem das
hakkani netzwerk profitiert dass er kein
at work ist nämlich für die sicherheit
in cabo zuständig und ließ den flughafen
umstellen der anschlag gab ihnen mehr
macht und eine gute rechtfertigung noch
mal härter durchzugreifen und
widersacher zu beseitigen so sieht es
also aus die hoffnung der usa das
abdriften afghanistans ins totale chaos
zu verhindern ist vollkommen davon
abhängig dass die taliban ihr wort
halten schließlich sind sie diejenigen
die jetzt an der macht sind aber wie
denkst du wird der neue gottesstaat der
taliban konkret aussehen können wir von
diesen fundamentalisten tatsächlich
erwarten genau das werden wir jetzt
klären
[Musik]
ein neuer taliban start
okay die taliban haben gewonnen sie
haben einen erdrutschsieg errungen und
sind fast 20 jahre nach der
amerikanischen invasion wieder an er
macht aber die große siegesparty ist
auch sie erst mal zu ende denn die
wahrheit ist dass sie nun mit einem
komplizierten szenario konfrontiert sind
es stimmt dass ihre beliebtheit beim
volk jetzt wesentlich größer ist als am
ende ihrer letzten regierungszeit vor 20
jahren dies liegt zum teil an der
extremen korruption der
zwischenzeitlichen regierung unter
institutionen der republik afghanistan
außerdem können sie sich nicht einfach
zurücklehnen und erwarten dass die liebe
des volkes ewig anhält wenn die taliban
stehen nun vor einem regelrechten
horrorszenario aus wirtschaftskrise
fraktions kämpfen und möglichen
widerstandsnester erinnere dich daran
dass die afghanische regierung furchtbar
abhängig von internationaler hilfe war
mehr als 75 prozent der
regierungsausgaben kamen aus spenden
anderer länder die nun ausgesetzt wurden
[Musik]
außerdem verspricht die abwanderung von
bürgern die vor den die band wien und
viele ihrer drakonischen maßnahmen die
das fernhalten von foul vom arbeitsmarkt
eine menge wirtschaftliche probleme zu
verursachen schließlich haben sie auch
versprochen gegen den opiumanbau
vorzugehen ein produkt mit dem sie sich
bisher finanziert haben das problem ist
dass dies nicht nur den lokalen
taliban-führern viele ressourcen
entziehen sondern auch die gewalt
zwischen den schmugglern und 100000 von
afghanen die im grunde von diesem handel
leben anheizen könnte und all das ist
ein perfekter cocktail für neue
konflikte
theoretisch wird erwartet dass die
taliban einen zwölfköpfigen rat an die
spitze setzen der afghanistan reagiert
darunter eine eher technokratische
regierung und dann eine art
revolutionsgarde die von den gebildet
wird vom kacani network mit anderen
worten das system könnte das des iran
stark ähneln auf jeden fall dürfen wir
nicht vergessen dass sie über eine
radikale und fundamentalistische gruppe
sprechen viele medien haben spekuliert
dass sie dieses mal gemäßigter sein wird
aber was auch immer der fall sein wird
was wir erwarten können ist nichts
weniger als eine sehr sehr radikale
regierung
[Musik]
in afghanistan wird nun eine sehr
strenge auslegung der scharia angewendet
frauen de facto aus dem öffentlichen
leben ausgeschlossen und viele verlieren
ihre bürgerrechte und ihren beruf
tatsächlich werden in vielen provinzen
bereits starke beschränkungen für frauen
eingeführt ihre präsenz in der
öffentlichkeit ihre
bildungsmöglichkeiten und sogar der
zugang zur gesundheitsversorgung
radio und fernsehsendungen mit musik und
stimmen von frauen in kandahar verboten
die taliban die in afghanistan herrschen
mögen für die usa das kleinere übel
darstellen aber sie sind für viele
menschen im land trotzdem eine
unglaubliche tragödie
umso mehr wenn wir berücksichtigen dass
damit die tendenz muslime schnellen der
zur mäßigung und ablehnung
fundamentalistische bewegungen gebrochen
wurde erfolg macht attraktiv und
fundamentalisten in vielen anderen
ländern werden sich durch den sieg
ermuntert sehen das pendel schwingt nun
wieder in richtung radikalisierung
außerdem stellt nun ein weiteres land
mit all seinen ressourcen in der hand
von extremisten den besten nährboden
findet export weitere radikale
strömungen oder kann man den taliban
wirklich trauen dass sie keine anderen
terroristischen organisationen dulden
unterstützen werden denn wenn sie ihr
wort nicht halten wird die katastrophe
total wollen können wir also ausgehen
nun im moment hat das ehrenwort taliban
bezüglich einer generalamnestie und
nicht verfolgung ihrer feinde mehr
löcher als ein schweizer käse schon
jetzt sind zahlreiche fälle von mord
folter und verfolgung ihre gegner
dokumentiert er scheint so dass sie sich
nicht wirklich zurückhalten können wenn
es um die letztliche erfüllung ihrer
ziele geht aber an dieser stelle ist
auch deine einschätzung gefragt glaubst
du die taliban werden ihr wort gegenüber
den usa dennoch halten und den
terrorismus in afghanistan einnähmen
denkst du dass sie mit der zeit
gemäßigte oder er radikaler werden
welche positionen sollte die
internationale gemeinschaft jetzt
einnehmen um sich gegen diese risiken
abzusichern teile deine meinung bitte
wie immer mit uns und auch allen anderen
im kommentarbereich wir werden
währenddessen den dritten teil unserer
afghanistan trilogie vorbereiten indem
wir über china russland und das
zukünftige potenzial des landes sprechen
werden vergiss also bitte nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren und das glöckchen zu
aktivieren damit du dieses video auf
keinen fall verpasst auf jeden fall
hoffe ich das euch unser heutiges video
gefallen hat falls ihr ergebnis mit
einem like und teilt ist auch mit euren
freunden macht gut und bis bald
[Musik]